un año tarde pero el líbano finalmente
tiene gobierno el primer ministro nayib
mikati logró reunir el apoyo suficiente
para formar un ejecutivo que se ponga al
frente de un país que lleva un año a la
deriva
la situación es difícil la situación es
muy difícil todos lo sabemos pero no es
imposible que nos unamos todos como
libaneses a mal en una hermosa la ley de
steven es una energía espero que podamos
lograr lo que la gente desea al ser un
área que el poner fin al colapso actual
y devolverle al líbano la dignidad y la
prosperidad si dios quiere radial unan
las dos olas de jarabes de la
mikati hereda un país colapsado el
desabastecimiento de gasolina paralizó
completamente a la nación durante el mes
de agosto tres cuartos de la población
viven en la pobreza en una crisis
económica agravada por la pandemia y por
la dependencia del líbano de la ayuda
externa una ayuda congelada mientras no
había gobierno
además del país todavía no se ha
recuperado de la explosión del puerto de
beirut hace más de un año sin respuestas
las víctimas culpan a la clase política
por corrupción y negligencia
deseamos que las cosas cambien pero no
confiamos en ellos pregunta a cualquiera
y te dirá que hemos perdido toda
confianza en ellos
mikati no es precisamente una cara nueva
en la política libanesa ya había sido
primer ministro en 2005 y 2011 por ahora
ha anunciado que el país deberá
apretarse el cinturón